[Music]
hey guys it's justine and today we are
unboxing the pixie it's a flying camera
now i think when you hear that you would
say well justine a flying camera isn't
that just a drone
yes you would be right but this is a
little bit different it it flies itself
you don't actually control it this is
the pixie and this is created by
snapchat and one of the things that i
think is really interesting is
snapchat's slogan has always been a
camera company now they were one of the
first to do
stories like they were the original 24
hour disappearing stories and then
everyone in the world basically ripped
them off and you've seen them like just
everywhere one thing that snapchat has
done very early on was they came out
with the snapchat spectacles and i was a
beyond obsessed i was so obsessed that i
ended up on the steve harvey show flew
out to chicago and went on the show to
show steve harvey how to use the
snapchat spec tools but all that to be
said
that snapchat has been doing a lot in
sort of this camera space and making
things easily integrate with snapchat
with your phone and this is no exception
i did get a little demo of this at the
snapchat office and i am so excited
because this one i actually get to unbox
a huge thank you to snapchat for giving
me one of these to show you guys this
isn't a sponsored video but they did
give me one of these early to check out
and show you and one of the things that
is cool is they have a bundle pack which
gives you two batteries which that is
this
right here these are the batteries i
definitely recommend doing this as a
i wouldn't say professional but a
semi-professional drone pilot having
extra batteries is definitely key
especially when you're dealing with
things like drones because it's really
hard to gauge the actual battery life of
these things because of the conditions
that you might be running into outside
if it's windy that means your drone is
working harder so that means you're
gonna have less battery life so highly
recommend if you are gonna get this or
ever getting a drone get the extra
batteries so enough talking let's open
this up i can't freaking wait to try
this because i just i'm so into the
design i love the colors i just think
snapchat is such a fun company and
they've really kind of done so many cool
things and this
my friends
is the pixie so let's open it up
[Music]
like i even love this little packaging
like it's just so
so well done
oh
okay all right this is one of those
unboxings where it's like not really a
surprise because you can actually see
what's inside
so surprise
here it is
it's so
small
now what's cool about this is it will
take off from your hand and then when
you put your hand under it again it will
land itself so there's no controller you
don't really control it it controls
itself using ai and the snapchat app
[Music]
look at you
you're so light
now this is under 249 grams so if anyone
is familiar with drone rules and laws
you don't have to register it with the
faa if it is under 249 grams of course
they do advise you to follow all drone
flying rules like don't fly by the
airport don't fly around people don't
fly over cars so if you are in a place
where you think you shouldn't fly you
probably shouldn't so be a responsible
pilot even though you're not piloting
you know what i mean okay so we've got
some safety warnings here
oh look aviation safety and regulation
so if you were confused as to any of
those things guess what
they have got a little documents for you
safety tips for flying your drone but
this is great because this may be some
people's first drones and you may not
actually know the rules so the fact that
they are including this i think is
important so be sure to go over these
the number one thing is check no fly
zones and keep the drone in sight at all
times which this doesn't actually fly
very far so you shouldn't have a problem
keeping it within sight here's some more
documents start here oh look at this it
even comes with a yellow usbc cable
that's cute
such a fun design
and here's the battery
let's just pop that in
just like so so this is the camera
sensor on the bottom
which is going to be kind of surveying
the land as it's flying and allowing you
to do that palm landing so
just like that magic and here's the dial
which will give you the different types
of modes that are on this little guy if
you're standby
oh look it's oh my gosh it's already
it's already on looks like you came with
a little bit of battery power whoa
like look at this it's so cute
oh this is okay this is great this is
very excited about this
it's a little carrying
cage
carrying bumper
like i don't even know what to call you
because you
you're cool
this little bumper
lets you kind of carry it around like a
little like a little bag like a little
purse and it protects your camera
look at this
[Music]
is that so low there it is
little tiny
bumper purse i can't wait to see what
you guys think of this because it's such
a unique little device i feel like it's
definitely not something that everyone
needs but
is this something that i want yes
all right let's get this all hooked up
to snapchat if you guys aren't following
me on snapchat i wonder i wonder what my
name would be on there could it be
ijustine yes it is here we go all right
hair pixie turn the doll to stand by
press the button on pixie for seven
seconds seven seconds okay
pear
i just needs pixie let's do it pairing
is
complete to get started find a clear
area away from trees buildings and water
select a flight mode and get started
okay the green led means your pixie is
ready to fly
push button to activate pixie pixy takes
off right from the palm of your hand
hover
reveal okay
follow
love that
orbit okay
when you're done place your hand under
pixie that's
it is that it okay
let's
let's see what
you guys can happens that i've
got a lot of stuff in the back there i
think we're done now
okay
and it landed okay so wait now is when
we review and import
put it on standby
and we're gonna review and import
there it is i'm currently in the process
of still redoing my studio and i just
moved over a lot of my stuff from
storage so i have a million and one
things
crammed inside of this room right now
it's not like most drones there's no
audio so here's our video we can go in
and we can edit it you can apply
different effects
and i can add this to my story we're not
going to add it yet because
the time of recording this it's not out
yet but now that you're actually seeing
it it is okay so now that this is all
set up i'm gonna turn this off i'm gonna
open up these batteries
these are the extra batteries now you
should be able to get i mean at least
five different flight modes depending
upon which ones you choose on one
battery charge which is why it's an
incredible idea to get these extra
batteries so it's kind of nice because
these will both charge at once in this
little case
that means
it is time to charge these up and take
this outside and test it out
i can't wait
i just tried to put the usba into the
usbc
yup
that's something that we have done
okay time to test it out so as you can
see i have it in its little
bumper bag bumper case bumper cars i
don't even know what to call this thing
but i absolutely love it i think it even
looks kind of cool and it's so light
that i don't even feel like i have
anything on so let's picture this
friends we're here at the park and i
want to take a few videos some selfies
if you will uh and i don't have anyone
around me
to um to take it for me because
jake's got his hands full over there
with a with a big camera so here we go
we're going to pop this out just like
that
and i'm going to switch it to standby
such a cute little chime
and i'm going to open up snapchat i'm
going to get it connected so the school
because in the app once it's actually
connected i can do hover review follow
orbit and favorite so you can go in and
you can actually change these different
settings so if i want the follow
to be my favorite i can do that but i
think i'm gonna keep the hover and we're
gonna have that set to take
photos only
so i can have it saved to my memories or
my camera roll and in case you lose it
there's an enable lost mode so hopefully
that doesn't happen to you or me but if
it does you can enable the lost mode and
it'll make a sound so you can try to
find it all right here we go
let's try this out for the first time
we're going to do
hover mode first switch it to hover and
the one note is it does look for your
face and you want this to be able to see
you so when you're putting this on your
palm you don't want to cover it like
this because it can't see you so make
sure you can see the camera fully before
you press the button and take off okay
oh my god i'm so nervous i'm so nervous
i'm like i'm not nervous there's no
reason to be nervous but we're gonna
press the button i've pressed it
it's counting down
and there we go
it's a little windy out right now so
it's not the most ideal conditions but
here we go you could do it
it's recording right now
okay and now i'm done
put my hand under it
and it landed oh yeah
this is pretty cool so it is a little
bit windy out right now so it was having
a little bit of a struggle obviously
this is such a small and tiny little
drone that any type of wind will affect
it so make sure if you are flying this
it is you know
not too windy of a day so the next one
we're gonna do is reveal
here we go
okay ready to reveal
you can do it
and there it goes
and it basically just follows its same
flight path
to come back to me
and
there we go
it's so cool oh my god i love this so
much let's do another one
follow this does
a 30 second and this is video so it will
follow me it'll recognize my face so you
can see this has a little green light
right there and
there's a white light there so those are
kind of like your little notifications
of what's happening so when it's white
it's recording and the green also
flashes when it's ready to land
okay it's recording someone over here
now if i okay oh so i'm going forward
so it's moving forward
[Music]
and 30 seconds is up and now we land
i mean this is great this is absolutely
just incredible and it automatically is
syncing to my phone all right let's
import these and see what they look like
and here they are they are already
connected and now i'm just saving them
to my camera roll so it's kind of cool
because not only can you post these
directly to your snapchat but you can
save them so if you do want to post
these anywhere else you can also do that
too and it's saving pretty quick i also
like when you do go to post it on
snapchat you can do different types of
editing so you can do kind of like a
little bounce and you can add different
effects to kind of make it whatever you
want okay i'm gonna swap out the battery
and then i'm gonna try the other two
modes on here all right so this is a
little battery pack and i've been
charging it on the go
and keep those batteries charging let's
do it oh nice it just gave me an alert
and told me that my battery is at 97
percent
that's exciting the next one we're going
to try is orbit so this will go all the
way around you which should be really
cool this is one of my favorites to do
when i'm flying drones and i love the
fact that i don't have to do anything i
just flip it over here there's our orbit
just gonna do it
the white lights have started recording
and
now we're orbiting
not too shabby hand out
and it lands
dude this is so fun all right i'm gonna
go to the favorites
we're gonna take some photos
okay posing
[Music]
[Applause]
so this is so much fun and obviously
this is such a small drone so if you are
flying it in conditions where it is a
little bit windy you are definitely
going to feel the effects of that but
all things considered this is really fun
and like i said in the beginning of this
video there are two different versions
of this and i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check it out
there is the standalone with just the
pixie and then there's the pixie with
two extra batteries if you guys aren't
already be sure to follow me on snapchat
and i'll be posting all of that content
on my snap so check it out ijustine and
that's me and i just seen we'll see you
later
bye
[Music]
you